what up guys welcome to the just for
early things youtube channel today i
have a special guest the whitest guy on
earth ken
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring the
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos ken tell
them what song you told me to react to
all right so the song is called chirac
by montana 300 chicago rapper
i mean this video is from like seven
years ago but it's got 32 million and
like this dude is not signed to a label
this is like straight up to some dude in
the streets okay
he actually has
bangers like all of his songs are
good i don't know this song am i going
to shimmy this song gets me hyped
am i going to bop my head yeah i shimmy
when it's a good song i'll give them a
little you know
he just goes up like i i don't know
where he stops for air sometimes
but comparing this to the song we just
listened to by little dirk which was
like one chorus like made me want to
actually get some rap where it's like
everything is like a little bit
different
[Music]
[Music]
i already like to be any [ __ ] that ever
looked at me wrong
hey man go that way b
hey man i'm down holding back on you
[ __ ] man straight up man y'all [ __ ]
better go watching my town that'd be 91
through 14 or something it's 15. i've
been bald i could have skipped college
i'm a bad boy with that big poppa 12
gauge when i head shot him put his head
open like a pinata like percy miller
i've been body come find your ass like
ben lott and i kill a clown over my
wallet
come find your ass like ben lott that's
clever no he's bust your head open like
a pinata like oh my gosh awesome
clever wait till you hear the red
bottoms all right give a [ __ ] if it was
ten dollars don't trust [ __ ] don't
trust [ __ ] i know these hoes like a
pimp scholar and this symbol be until
the day i drop and these stupid thoughts
don't getting out of these dick riders
try to steal from me don't feel the heat
when that leg popping my whack a [ __ ]
and then walk away with blood on my
shoes that's red bottom bought a new gun
with two clips what did he say what
walk away said my wife whack a [ __ ] and
walk away with blood on my shoes that's
red oh gosh that's so clever this dude's
great that's clever i can't wait to use
it and that [ __ ] stick to my hip like i
glued it i hope you do trip as soon as
you do it i'll pull that [ __ ] out
canine united kiss yo ass good night
like big bang that smooches no top
that's clueless i'm ruthless i do this
i'm bawling these hoes yeah they all on
my pool stick and you mad at your main
[ __ ] because that [ __ ] bumping my new
[ __ ] got a game foul and the ref dirty
keep the green on me like a test jersey
telling opposition i ain't never worried
keep the dirty on me like i'm stepping
curry i can see you [ __ ] like a
miniskirt keep talking you don't get it
first and the toughest what you gon get
it worse now go order up about 20 shirts
r.i.p with they face on it how to show
the ass how that semi work yeah they got
smoked april 21st the next time you see
them gonna be in a hurst always saying
something but ain't spraying nothing
when it's beef on wait for nothing if i
see your eyebrow day in public and i'm
shooting [ __ ] like a say production got
word they'd be out there every night i'm
talking deeper than barry white we gonna
ride past with that iron blast and start
flipping [ __ ] like jesse white they
catching bullets he randy moss he's
tyrell and see jerry rice and i'm a
[ __ ] monster in a pair of mics and
it's funny homie looks very okay so i
have some themes for this song so he's
letting you know
one that he's like hard yes so he's not
afraid to shoot you right he's letting
you know also the ladies they love him
i actually don't know well yeah i mean
he did have that one where it's like you
mad at your main [ __ ] because you've
been i think he's always saying that
like they're not gonna get [ __ ] like
they do stuff for him you know sexually
but like money
you're just i'm using you for your body
pretty much so one thing that i want you
to hear is like
every couple
probably ever like 30 to 45 seconds he
goes up in octave and the rap skit are
going to get quicker
so there's also a lot of sports
references i'm not sure if you're
picking up on them he goes like i keep
the 30 on me like i'm stephen curry
because that's the shirt he wears got
the green on me like a gesture
and he goes i'm catching bullets i like
randy moss terrell owens jerry rice
there's wide receivers oh
and then or hall of fame wide receivers
so
he's sprinkling in a lot of references
as well but yeah
good good [ __ ]
i'm ready to roll up like a blunt i
don't like [ __ ] i hunt hoodie on like a
monk i'm boys in the hood with that pump
this [ __ ] got kicked like a punt it
usually sit in my trunk but for today is
riding shotgun six [ __ ] like the front
and if this [ __ ] running this [ __ ]
done imma soak a [ __ ] lucky in the tub
these rappers actors like ice cube to
tell dope boy to come pick them up [ __ ]
[ __ ] i never liked them got no problem
with killing one i do real hints and
don't brag about it just rap about it i
don't give a [ __ ] i remember way back
when we was broke we was crying mama
high as hell she was a loving mother but
to other [ __ ] she was clientele
and i remember begging her to stop and
every single night when i told her that
imma get big and buy a bunch of guns and
kill every [ __ ] that a soda crack is
almost 20 years later that's so clever
he literally does he literally just put
in his like [ __ ] childhood struggle
his mom's like addiction to crack
cocaine wow in the wrap as to like why
he does this right like it's literally
to get his mom away from
her addiction to crack wow what
that that was that was like beautiful
honestly
let me double check something okay
now she finally subbed but that was the
[ __ ] that i prayed about i thank god i
made it out damn it feels good to go
pick up my mama and take her out the
tony got paper now all in my bank
account and it ain't [ __ ] the debate
about if you cross me like jesus i'll
come back where haters be outside your
crib like we staking out it's really
[ __ ] up in my city i'm sorry but i'm
about to add to the body count i'm rocky
platformer russian and shaw you [ __ ]
exactly what i'll be about my choppers
say [ __ ] on them [ __ ] when spitting i
think that it might get a potty mouth i
might come based on like kobe bryant
they went back in all three ending body
yeah keep running your mouth from a
running your health paramedics they're
gonna bring bodies out i'm signing you
[ __ ] like say rock and roll on the
streets that they didn't let bobby out
be stopped at the mall stopped at the
studio better be stopped at your mama
house but my time hopping on hello to
the pop and now carter's that's taking
the garbage out moment of silence text
messages around my city the moment they
find it out back and block everything we
gon back everything that's the motto
when we riding out the ratchet stay on
me just know it was on me whenever if
ever you saw me out been playing with
eyes since the age of nine shout out to
my daddy he taught me how my dad was a
killer my mom was an addict and [ __ ]
grew up in a
i love this guy
i do
fire
oh my gosh you gotta find it you gotta
listen to his trap queen remix
like jabari now see [ __ ] were sleeping
on me but i just woke them up and they
saying they sorry
stacking dope rapping no lacking pull
packing phone blasting soul snatching so
tagging cold bastard better close your
mouth and get a close casket show you
what i'm saying like closed captions for
the men too make them disappear when i
spit fire that's old magic i put that
chopper to a [ __ ] top and then let it
fly go go gadgets my [ __ ] [ __ ] say
[ __ ] the city get straight face that's
no passion i'm the illest [ __ ] that you
ever heard i'm the flyest killer that
you've ever seen and never [ __ ] [ __ ]
ever jump stupid imma catch a body like
a trampoline [ __ ] i'm freddy krueger in
a hockey mask bout to kick those like
karate class that's a [ __ ] wait how to
stash you better tell the truth like a
polygraph for a false move and that
shoddy blast leave a [ __ ] sniff like a
body cast and we don't know nothing
about nothing [ __ ] we was out of town
with somebody ass real [ __ ] i'm a father
first my sons need me ain't bailing on
them people real [ __ ] doing real [ __ ]
and if i get guard ain't telling on them
no tool ain't never going i ain't mad
with that man alone i'm only god knows
where the hell i'm going make a [ __ ]
wish that he was never born these [ __ ]
he's gonna make him wish he was never
born that's a that's a threat yeah i
think there's a lot of threats
i think that he's he's uh he's put some
threats out there but he he but they're
they're the guys that sold his mom crack
is that the threats like is that who
it's directed towards or is it just like
the other gang i i think it's just
anyone who's trying to get in the way of
like him trying to i guess bring his
family because he's like i'm a father
like
in the way of like
that and like even though he's like it's
[ __ ] up like he even says like like my
city's [ __ ] up but i'm about to add to
the body count yeah i know i heard so
he's aware that there's issues in
chicago with uh maybe gang violence but
he is aware that there is a problem but
he is also a part of the problem
but he makes some fire music
the bro put a price
not miami but i'm wearing heat like i
play for my coming night and put the
nods on with the law clip deandre jordan
okay so that was two sports references
not sure if you got those i don't i
don't watch sports and he said i'm from
shyrack not miami but i'm wearing heat
which would be gone oh i play for them
like miami heat the basketball team
and then he says i keep the
nine clip on me
right it's like you know clips for the
magazine
deandre jordan who used to be the center
for the los angeles clippers
at the time of this he was the best
defensive center in the league so
clever he's got it beyonce
he's got a lot of friends too
right now so that's what made me think
of that right where it's like there's
all these people in the background who
literally say zero words but they are
there
they i love you
yeah i mean like it's basically like bad
backup dancers but like
the difference between the backup
dancers you see in pop videos and like
the
thugs it adds something yeah i mean it
shows that yeah he's not alone when he's
out here like
talking that game what's up i'm at night
to put the knobs on with the long clip
deandre jordan
i love that guy
yeah i hope he's well
does he still make music uh he he had an
album come out like not too long did he
fall off i i haven't been as honest as i
should be but i like i like the old
stuff you know i'm the purist of montana
300 so i'll have to see if he's got any
one to five what do you rate it oh that
song's a five that sound goes [ __ ]
hard in the paint uh
four yeah that's fair i i like a little
more boppy there's there's repetitive
themes and also it's he kind of ends up
just yelling at you yeah
he's kind of yelling
like i love it because like to me he's
like getting no it's very crazy every
time yeah like he's getting every verse
he's getting like
harder
but
yeah
i like that i like him
i hope he's well
okay guys let us know in the comments
one to five what do you rate that song
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bringing that notification bell you can
find ken on tick tock ken
yeah it's just kind of i'm making it
really
tell them your instagram handle it's wax
on wax off
my last name is wax
w-a-k-s i know this is backwards and i
don't cares but wax on wax off with my
last name being waks
i believe in you
okay guys thanks for watching i'll talk
to you guys next time